let's review a little bit of what we've
gone over and I think it helps to see
the whole process again just so it
really sinks into your brain and I've
drawn the banks in a different
arrangement this time but just as a
review this is a bank with a little bit
less reserves the green right here is
their reserves you can either be
deposits at the Federal Reserve or these
could actually be Federal Reserve notes
and we all know that is as dollars or
cash this is another Bank with slightly
more slightly more reserves and just
like I said in the last video I I'm
drawing the reserves at the top of the
asset side now so that we can compare it
directly with the demand deposits or the
liabilities of this Bank most banks have
other liabilities but I've just assumed
that all of them are demand deposit and
this that's this magenta square here and
of course their equity is the blue right
there
make sure I have it that's their equity
and of course either if these are either
Federal Reserve notes or these are these
are deposits within the Reserve Bank
those are of course liabilities for the
Reserve Bank itself so let me draw a
line from there to there so this is you
know this is a liability for the Reserve
Bank this is liability if I if these
were the if these were deposits if these
were essentially demand accounts with
the Reserve Bank then you know we could
even divide them up a little bit and
separate okay this guy has this much and
if you can see that that color is not so
good this guy has this much this guy is
this much but if these are all Federal
Reserve notes and they kind of all come
out of the same bucket and what we
learned in in the last video and is is
that the Federal Reserve they don't say
we want the money supply to be X or Y
they always talk about in terms of
interest rates they always say our
target interest rate or the Federal
Reserve rate is now going to be X and so
let's go over our mechanics a little bit
more on how open market transactions
help to make those rates happen so let's
say that on day one or before the Fed
does anything this Bank has a little bit
of extra reserves this Bank has a little
bit less reserves so there's a couple of
things that this Bank could do with
these extra reserves it could either
maybe make do some more lending so it
could actually
it's reserved maybe it's let's say it's
that I don't want to get too specific
with the numbers let's say it's at a at
a 20 percent reserve ratio this ratio to
this is 20 percent and it it can be as
low as a you know it would feel
comfortable being at a 15 percent
reserve ratio so roughly 1/4 of its
reserves could be used for doing
something else and what could it be used
for so let's say this portion of its
reserves could be used for something
else well it could lend them to another
bank who maybe needs reserves so that
could be this right here
this bank maybe want some reserves and
then it would add it up on here I don't
know the last video I I filled in the
reserve down here but actually they're
not replacing other assets they would
have actually just been added to the
balance sheet at the bank so I should
have drawn them on top and I'll do that
in a second but the other option that
this Bank could do is that they could
actually do more lending since the
reserve ratio was higher than they want
they can actually create checking
accounts like we saw in the last couple
of videos but with that said let's say
that they want to you know this guy
wants to borrow some this guy's willing
to lend so I'm all the best not his only
alternative he could do some more he
could create checking accounts
essentially with it and do some more
lending with it and let's say in this
reality right now given how much
reserves are on the banking systems at
the current rate let me write that right
here current rate the current rate is 6%
now the Federal Reserve says you know
what I would like to expand the money
supply and they don't say directly they
don't tell us you know in our newspapers
and it maker press release a we would
like the official m1 value of the money
supply to go from 15 trillion to 20
trillion dollars they don't say that
they say we we are going to lower the
federal funds rate to 5 percent so let's
say they want a federal funds rate let
me write that Fed Funds rate they are
setting to be 5 percent the federal the
the governors of the Federal Reserve
Bank sit together and Bernanke comes out
and says we are lowering the federal
funds rate from 2 5% so with that 5%
means is that their target rate is now 5
percent so this is a target this is a
target so what they're saying is is we
are going to perform open market
transaction
in such a way that now when this bank
offers money to this Bank is going to
reduce its rate from 6% to 5% or another
way to put it they're going to do open
market transactions or operations in
such a way that the demand might also go
down for the reserves so this guy might
be willing to pay less for borrowing
from this guy instead of being willing
to pay 6% he'll be willing to pay 5%
remember on any in any transaction both
people have to agree on it so how do
they do that and I think we've
reasonably filled up familiar with the
mechanics now so the Federal Reserve
could do is that they can print some
notes they can print some of their notes
those are assets cuz they haven't done
anything with them yet those are assets
and then there's a corresponding
liability I'll do that in a slightly
different shade of green there's a
corresponding liability these are notes
outstanding right which I should have
done all of this in this darker shade of
green these are the liabilities the
light green are the assets the notes
themselves and what the what the Federal
Reserve does because they want to they
don't want to become an insolvent bank
so they want to do by the most liquid
safest assets out there and it actually
makes a lot of sense and well we'll
touch on this in a lot of different ways
but what they say is we're gonna take
this money and inject it into the system
by buying Treasuries with it and they
could be buying those Treasuries from
your grandmother they could be buying it
from China they could be buying it from
Russia they could be buying it for me
they could be borrowing it from my uncle
regardless of who they buy it from let's
say they buy it from someone in the US
so that we don't get confused right now
let's say they buy it from my uncle so
this is my uncle let me see if I can
draw him this is my uncle he's holding a
Treasury right now you an IOU from the
government that's what he has he wasn't
willing to sell it before but let's say
the Treasury of sorry the Federal
Reserve has printed more money and now
the federal and he's like well you know
I'm not gonna sell it now but if
someone's willing to offer me a little
bit more money for it maybe I'm willing
to part with my my Treasury bill so the
Federal Reserve and he doesn't know that
he's selling to the Federal Reserve he
just sees like it's selling into a
market the same way that when you buy a
stock you don't know who you're buying
it from or who you
selling it to and all of that so all of
a sudden someone goes out there and is
willing to pay a slightly higher price
for these Treasury bills these I use
from the government and he's like Oh
fine yeah that's a good price I'm going
to sell them to the whoever's buying it
it turns out that it's actually the
Federal Reserve that's buying it so the
Federal Reserve all of a sudden has my
uncle would be a big-time operator if
the Federal Reserve only bought from him
he would have to have hundreds of
billions of dollars of these things and
he doesn't have his IOU anymore
what does he have right now that IOU is
now exchanged for a dollar bill or
hundreds of billions of dollar bills or
or reserve deposits at the Federal
Reserve all of the same but we'll just
to keep the abstraction solid for right
now we'll keep it in terms of dollar
bills so his IOUs
he sold in exchange for these dollar
bills and what does he do with them this
is hundreds of billions of dollars he's
not gonna stuff it all into his mattress
he's going to deposit it into the
banking system so maybe he gives a
little bit to this bank up here and this
is what I a slight mistake that I did in
the last video I was adding it below but
it's not replacing other assets it's a
new assets so let's say he put some of
it here my uncle did after he sold his
Treasuries and let's say he puts some of
it in this Bank or maybe it's a bunch of
people's uncle's and they all don't go
to the same Bank let me do that in a
slightly different shade of green just
so you know this is I'll do it in blue
just you know this is like a new deposit
but it's close enough to Green that I
think you get the idea
and of course he has an offsetting his
checking account if you didn't have one
already now he has one so their
liabilities increase a little bit so a
couple of things will happen just in
terms how does this affect the rate that
they're charging to each other well now
all of a sudden this banks reserve
ratios gotten a little bit better his
assets and his liabilities increased
right his assets increased by the amount
of my uncle's deposit but so did the
liabilities because he's had the demand
deposit but it came at a ratio of
reserves to demand deposit 100% so this
would have improved his reserve ratio if
you now take if you now or take the
ratio of this height to this height it's
not going to improve
right so now he doesn't need money this
bank doesn't need money as bad in order
to improve it's a reserve ratio and
likewise this bank now even has an even
better reservation he already had more
reserves than he needed and now he got
even more he has even even better
reserve ratio so now this guy's demand
for them for reserves is a little bit
lower and this guy's supply of reserves
is a little bit higher so this guy is
only going to be willing to pay a little
bit less for new reserves from this bank
and this guy he's willing to charge less
now cuz he has more he doesn't know what
to do with it he can't he you know he he
doesn't know enough people who want to
borrow more money so he wants to
actually lend off some Mis reserves so
just by increasing the supply of
reserves and decreasing the demand of
reserves the current rate if the Fed
does this appropriately will go to 5%
and let's say it only went to five and a
half percent then the Fed will keep
doing this and then it'll go to five
percent if it goes too far four goes to
four and a half percent maybe the Fed
will reverse the transaction the Fed
will actually go out there and sell
these Treasury notes but I also want to
make make you clip make it clear that
the point of this although it does
affect the interest rate and that's what
the Federal Reserve always talks about
in terms of their target rates the net
effect of injecting more reserves into
the system is it increases the lending
power of the bank and if we have let's
say a 10% reserve ratio every dollar
that you inject every dollar that that
the that is injected into the banking
system right there that Bank can then do
ten dollars worth of lending and let's
say that bank lends it all to this bank
let's say he he lends all of that so now
this turns to an asset which is a loan
to this Bank
so this Bank then has he borrowed he
hasn't this isn't a demand deposit
anymore this is now a loan from this
Bank he has more reserves now that's his
reserves I shouldn't be doing it in that
purple color I shouldn't to be sticking
to green but the bottom line is wherever
those resort reserves are it doesn't
matter which banks they sit in but they
enable every dollar of that increased
reserves enables ten dollars of lending
right this Bank now can create ten
dollars of checking accounts
through lending and so even though the
the Federal Reserve talks in terms of
interest rates and I'll talk a lot about
why they're more focused on interest
rates than absolute measures of the
money supply even though they talk in
terms of interest rates by lowering the
by performing these open market
transactions that that in effect lower
the interest rate by increasing the
amount of reserves out there they're
actually increasing banks lending
capacity so the amount of reserves
that's base money or it's or that you
could almost view it as the liability
side of the of the federal funds the
reserve deposits that's base money
that's m0 and you get a multiplier
effect for m1 which is the amount of
demand deposits because in this Bank it
got more reserves and then it can create
a bunch of demand deposits like we
learned earlier so by saying that
they're lowering the rates they're
essentially saying that they're going to
perform open market transactions that
will inject reserves into the banking
system which will allow them to keep
their reserve ratios in line but make a
lot more loan so significantly increase
the the m1 and then the other loser the
broader definitions of money supply I
will see you in the next video